[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap à
ça oui j'ai demandé un jeune de me faire
un son c'est
ces résidences et intéresse ici alors ça
va en petits série sarajevo ah bah oui
bien la famille bien dans la famille
très bien les audiences de la première
semaine magnifique on la
retrouve et sarah ou
formidable et
ce brillant avocat la cua en échappe
m di vizio
auquel otba
faire l'émission terrade
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si j'ai bien compris il est contre les
passes mais il fait quand même le
trottoir
[Applaudissements]
ça va pas l'humeur plus via des coups de
fil ce week-end la brasse fabrice hôtel
alors parlons peu parlons bien tu te
souviens cyril du jour on s'est
rencontrés tu te rappelles de la
première question que j'ai posée oui tu
m'as demandé je me rappelle très bien
combien je gagne
quand c'est vrai j'ai fait savoir
franchement elle m'a demandé combien je
gagnerai bon admettons mais la deuxième
alors la deuxième question que je te
poser c'est quoi pour deuxième prénom
est là tu m'as dit valérie série c'est
mon deuxième prénom valérie kendrick
c'est pas un prénom président alors son
nom m'échappe sexe et comme comme il
serait bon choix même pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame ou mademoiselle mouchoirs
les franges ou tu peux le faire toi en
regardant la france au fond des yeux à
moi on soit madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir les fans vous
vanter ses rues en tant que coach je
suis fier de toi oui parce que je me
rends compte que je ne suis pas présenté
cyril donc m'a demandé d'être sa
directrice de campagne pour 2022 je suis
sandrine sa coach
cyril j'ai fait comme un à dire je
préparais un petit dossier sur sa
candidature secrète secret l'élection
présidentielle voilà c'est quoi ce
délire à qui est inquiète mais j'étais
hyper chaud là dessus je gère j'ai alors
tu serais donc tu l'as dit combien il
reste deux jours avant le premier tour
deux cents dix neuf 19 jours c'est quoi
c'est rien ce sont dix neuf jours c'est
le temps qu'il faut à doc gynéco pour
prendre son petit déjeuner
le 110e jours c'est le temps qu'il faut
à bernard montiel pour fignoler son
bronzage point soleil
mais 110 nos jours c'est le temps qu'il
faut à benjamin castaldi % marié dont
119 x
tu sais j'ai ri une élection c'est une
rencontre entre un homme points et une
super belle la france va alors ma
stratégie est simple dans le métier on
appelle ça la stratégie de la boîte de
nuit the night club stratégie est déjà
allé en boîte ouais tu peux alors tu es
d'accord si tu arrive trop tôt tout le
monde est encore lucide probabilité de
pécho 0 alors alors que si paris cinq
minutes avant la fermeture de la boîte
l'a emballé c'est pesé tu es sûr de
soulever le gros lot ne t'inquiète pas
tu n'auras pas grand-chose à faire un
tous les petits candidats les mélenchon
les le pen les maquereaux tout ça que tu
les laisses partir devant ok tu les
laisses s'épuiser mais attention
attention tu les invite dans balance en
poste et moi pendant ce temps là ni vu
ni connu je serai en coulisses avec un
petit carnet pour noter toutes leurs
conneries bon ok peut-être qu'il va
falloir un gros carnet
je sais ce que tu te dis sylvie bonne
pioche ses bienfaits l'a recruté c'est
là sa cavale savoir comment s'habiller
les vêtements là c'est juste pour les
missions et les apprêter
alors c'est pas président savait pas
président alors qu'à l'école qu'à
l'école si des amis bien intentionnés
veulent s'offrir des costumes sur mesure
oui non parce que c'est déjà arrivé avec
françois
si des amis bien intentionnés insiste
pour t'offrir des beaux costumes un
conseil prend les
[Rires]
airs il a confiance en moi oui oui sans
moi oui j'ai confiance en toi et tu sais
pourquoi pourquoi parce que comme disait
le génie argentin
son nom m'échappe non pas messi mais non
mais pas mais non pas messi
dgo voilà diego armando maradona bien en
taux moyen maradona aurait dit toi cyril
tu as un avantage sur les politiques les
politiques eux ils sont publics toi tu
es populaire
je fais un chèque
non pas chez eux et je te dis la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]